>>> THAT UNPRECEDENTED FBI
SEARCH OF THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
HOME IS TRIGGALING A POLITICAL
FIRESTORM ON THE RIGHT.
DONALD TRUMP SAYS HE'S THE
VICTIM HERE, NOT THE BAD GUY,
AND MOST REPUBLICANS ARE GETTING
IN LINE BEHIND HIM.
IN A STATEMENT, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT CALLS MONDAY'S SEARCH,
QUOTE, PROSECUTORIAL MISCONDUCT.
THE WEAPONIZATION OF THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND AN ATTACK BY REDICAL
LEFT DEMOCRATS WHO DON'T WANT ME
TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT IN 2024 AND
WILL DO ANYTHING TO STOP
REPUBLICANS AND CONSERVATIVES IN
THE UPCOMING MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT OFFERED NO
FACTS.
NO FACTS TO BACK UP ANY OF THAT.
WE SHOULD NOTE THE SEARCH
WARRANT WAS ISSUED BY A FEDERAL
MAGISTRATE, BUT 91 DAYS NOW TO
THE MIDTERM ELECTION AND AS
TRUMP PREPARES TO RUN AGAIN IN
2024, IT IS CLEAR TRUMP AND MOST
OTHER REPUBLICANS SEE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MOBILIZE THE GOP
BASE HERE.
PERHAPS MOST STRIKING IN THE
REPUBLICAN REACTION WERE THE
WORDS OF THE MAN WHO MIGHT BE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN
LEADER KEVIN McCARTHY.
AGAIN, THE WAURRRANT WAS LEGALL
EXECUTED BUT McCARTHY CALLED IT
INTOLERABLE.
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND,
McCARTHY SAID, PRESERVE YOUR
DOCUMENTS.
AND CLEAR YOUR CALENDAR.
WITH ME NOW TO SHARE THE
REPORTING AND THEIR INSIGHTS,
KAITLAN COLLINS IS STILL WITH US
ALONG WITH AYESHA RASCOE, LEIGH
ANN CALDWELL OF THE WASHINGTON
POST.
IT'S CLEAR TO ME, TELL ME IF I'M
WRONG TO CONNECT THESE DOTS.
NUMBER ONE, THIS IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
NUMBER TWO, THE RIGHT HAS LONG
HAD GRIEVANCES ABOUT THE DEEP
STATE, THE FBI, ET CETERA.
WE ALSO HAD A COUPLE WEEKS WHERE
THE POLITICAL CONSAG HAS BEEN,
HMM, THINGS ARE GETTING BETTER
FOR THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY JUST SEE THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE TO LIGHT IT UP.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, I THINK THAT, I
DON'T KNOW IF WE CAN CONNECT
THOSE TWO THINGS.
LIKE, WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS DOING IS COMPLETELY
SEPARATE FROM THE POLITICAL
REALM OF DEMOCRATS, BUT THIS
DOES STEP ON DEMOCRATS' VICTORY
LAP A LITTLE BIT OF THEY HAVE
HAD A REALLY GOOD LAST SEVERAL
WEEKS HEADING INTO THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS TO BE ABLE TO
CELEBRATE THOSE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
SO IT JUST CROWDS IT OUT A
LITTLE BIT, BUT THEY STILL HAVE
THAT.
AS FAR AS WHAT REPUBLICANS ARE
SAYING, THEY THINK THIS IS GOING
TO BE VERY GOOD FOR REPUBLICANS
AND FOR THE FORMER PRESIDENT
SHOULD HE DECIDE TO RUN.
WE'LL SEE IF THAT BEARS TRUTH.
BUT YOU KNOW, DONALD TRUMP HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THE MOST TENUOUS
PART OF POLITICS.
WE'RE NOT REALLY SURE WHO IT'S
GOING TO IMPACT AND WHO'S GOING
TO BENEFIT FROM IT.
AND WE DON'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT
THIS YET.
>> YOU SEE THIS FIRESTORM ON THE
RIGHT NOW, 90 DAYS TO THE
ELECTION.
CAN YOU SUSTAIN IT FOR 90 DAYS?
DID MERRICK GARLAND, FOLLOWING
THE IDEA YOU KEEP THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OUT OF AN ELECTION,
60 DAYS, 90 DAYS, WE'LL FIND OUT
THESE THINGS, BUT THESE ARE SOME
OF THE 2024 PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES REACTING.
RON DeSANTIS SAYS THIS SHOWS
WE'RE A BANANA REPUBLIC.
MARCO RUBIO, SOMETHING WE HAVE
SEEN MANY TIMES FROM THIRD WORLD
MARXIST DICTATORS.
WE MUST SEE THE PROBABLE CAUSE
AFFIDAVIT BEFORE MAKING A
SKR
JUDGMENT.
ASIA HUTCHINSON IS NOT A TRUMP
FAN.
HE WANTS TO RAISE QUESTIONS, BUT
HE'S ESSENTIALLY SAYING MERRICK
GARLAND, MAKE IT PUBLIC.
IF THAT PROBABLE CAUSE WARRANT
IS DAMNING, THAT HURTS TRUMP.
>> IT OBVIOUSLY DOES HURT TRUMP.
FOR PEOPLE LIKE DeSANTIS OR EVEN
MIKE PENCE, I'M SURE THEY'RE
QUIETLY CRYING OVER THIS
HAPPENING BECAUSE, LOOK, THERE
WOULD BE NOTHING BETTER FOR
DeSANTIS TO SAY I'M TAKING UP
THE MANTLE OF TRUMP, BUT HE'S
OFF TO THE SIDE RIGHT NOW.
I'M GOING TO FIGHT FOR YOU AND
I'M GOING TO KEEP DOING IT WHILE
TRUMP IS HAVING SOME ISSUES.
SO I MEAN, I THINK THIS IDEA,
OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS A POLITICAL
SHOW.
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THE
POLITICS OF IT, BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK ADD THE LEGAL RAMIFICATIONS
OF IT, I'M NOT A LAWYER, BUT I
DON'T THINK IT'S GREAT TO HAVE
THE FBI RAID YOUR HOUSE, RIGHT?
THAT'S NOT A GREAT THING.
AND THE LEGAL THING, LIKE THE
LEGAL ISSUES COULD SUPERSEDE THE
POLITICAL ISSUES.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
>> THAT'S A CONVERSATION
WASHINGTON HAS HAD FOR A LONG
TIME.
HE'S BEEN TWICE IMPEACHED.
HE'S THE GUY WHO SAID HE COULD
STAND ON FIFTH AVENUE AND SHOOT
SOMEBODY AND GET AWAY.
HE PLAYS THE VICTIM CARD VERY
WELL.
THEY'RE RAISING MONEY OFF THIS
AS SOON AS IT HAPPENED.
LET'S LISTEN, KAITLAN COLLINS,
TO THE VOICE OF DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S INTERESTING OR IRONIC, PICK
YOUR WORD FOR IT, DAY.
HE IS SCHEDULED TO CALL IN TO A
POLITICAL RALLY FOR SARAH PALIN,
FORMER ALASKA GOVERNOR, WHO IS
NOW RUNNING FOR CONGRESS.
LISTEN TO DONALD TRUMP.
>> THAT'S RIGHT, ANOTHER DAY IN
PARADISE.
THIS WAS A STRANGE DAY.
YOU PROBABLY ALL READ ABOUT IT,
BUT VERY IMPORTANT.
>> SO TELL US THE TRUTH IN TERMS
OF THE REPORTING.
IT'S NOT A GOOD DAY WHEN THE FBI
RAIDS YOUR HOUSE.
TRUMP IS VERY GOOD, VERY
EFFECTIVE, I KNOW DEMOCRATS OUT
THERE GET ANGRY WHEN YOU SAY
THIS, BUT VERY EFFECTIVE AT
PLAYING THE VICTIM CARD AND
TURNING CRISES INTO POLITICAL
OPPORTUNITY.
BUT THEY HAVE TO BE RATTLED IN
TRUMP WORLD.
>> HE'S CERTAINLY TRYING TO USE
IT TO HIS ADVANTAGE.
OBVIOUSLY, THIS BOLSTERS THIS
ARGUMENT THAT HE'S LONG HELD
WHICH IS BASICALLY THE
GOVERNMENT IS PITTED AGAINST
HIM.
THEY ARE CONSTANTLY GOING AFTER
HIM, WITCH HUNT, REVERSE
WATERGATE WHICH IS HOW HE'S
FRAMING THIS.
THAT HAS BEEN A LONG STANDING
POSITION OF THIS.
IT'S TRUE THAT COULD BOLSTER
THAT.
YOU'RE HEARING IT FROM
REPUBLICANS AND HIS OWN FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO SAY IF HE DOES
DECIDE TO RUN IN 2024, THEY
BELIEVE THIS WILL PUT WIND IN
HIS SAILS.
YOU ALSO HAVE TO LOOK AT HOW
THIS WENT DOWN YESTERDAY.
THESE FBI AGENTS SHOWED UP AT
MAR-A-LAGO AT WE'RE TOLD BETWEEN
8:00 AND 10:00 IN THE MORNING.
IT WASN'T UNTIL ABOUT 7:00 P.M.
EASTERN LAST NIGHT THAT THE
PRESIDENT, FORMER PRESIDENT
CONFIRMED IN A STATEMENT THAT
YES, IT HAD HAPPENED.
THAT WAS THE FIRST CONFIRMATION,
HIM IN HIS OWN WORDS SAYING THIS
HAPPENED.
I THINK THERE'S PART OF THIS
WHERE HE'S USING THIS TO HIS
POLITICAL ADVANTAGE, BUT THERE'S
THE OTHER ASPECT OF THIS WHERE
PEOPLE IN HIS OWN ORBIT ARE
SAYING THEY WENT AND EXECUTED A
SEARCH WARRANT ON HIS RESIDENCE.
THEY HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT THERE IS SOMETHING MORE
THERE BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE IT'S
SO EXPLOSIVE AND DELICATE AND
SENSITIVE THAT THERE MUST BE
SOMETHING IF THEY TOOK THAT
STEP.
WHETHER OR NOT THERE IS REMAINS
TO BE SEEN.
>> THEY'RE ATTACKING THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, BUT EVEN LONG
SERVING REPUBLICANS IN THIS TOWN
WHO KNOW MERRICK GARLAND WELL
FROM HIS DAYS MOVING UP FROM THE
FEDERAL BENCH, THEY DON'T THINK
HE WOULD SIGN OFF ON THIS UNLESS
HE SAW SOMETHING THAT GAVE HIM
GOOD REASON TO DO SO.
SO, THIS MORNING OUTRAGE AND
CONDEMNATIONWIFTLY POURING IN
FROMOP REPUBLICANS FOLLOWING
THE UNPRECEDENTED FBI SEARCH.
THAT IS A SEARCH OF FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S MAR-A-LAGO
RESIDENTS.
THE TOP REPUBLICAN MEMBER AND
HOUSE INTEL TWEETED THIS AS THE
LEAD REPUBLICAN ON HOUSE
PERMANENT SELECT COMMITTEE ON
INTEL.
I AM DEMANDING AN IMMEDIATE
BRIEFING BY FBI DIRECTOR WRAY
REGARDING THE NATIONAL SECURITY
RISK THAT ALLEGEDLY ROSE TO THE
LEVEL OF ORDERING A RAISE ON
THE PRESIDENT OF A FORMER
PRESIDENT.
>> THIS IS FROM THE REPUBLICAN
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER, HE
TWEETS AT ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND TO, QUOTE,
PRESERVE YOUR DOCUMENTS AND
CLEAR YOUR CALENDAR.
JOINING US NOW TO DISCUSS ALL
OF THIS IS CNN ANCHOR AND
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST JOHN
AVLON.
THE JOHN ANALYSIS, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US THIS
MORNING.
I WANT TO GO TO YOU FIRST, WE
LEARNED ABOUT THIS NOT FROM THE
DOJ, NOT FROM THE FBI, BUT FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP HIMSELF.
HE WAS NOT NECESSARILY
CONFIRMING THIS.
HE WAS BLASTING IT OUT THERE.
HE APPEARS TO SEE THIS AS
BENEFICIAL.
HOW DOES HE THINK THIS IS GOING
TO HELP HIM?
>> IT APPEARS AS THOUGH HE
COULD TURN OUT TO BE A MARTYR
AND THE SITUATION.
YOU KNOW ME, I AM USUALLY AN
APOLOGIST FOR TRUMP BUT I AM A
REPUBLICAN.
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM SOCIAL
CONSERVATIVES IS THEIR OUTRAGE
AT THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY.
WE UNDERSTAND THE DOJ HAS
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
BERTHOLD.
BUT, IT IS REALLY HARD TO LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENED YESTERDAY AS
ANYTHING SHORT OF AN OVERREACH
BY THE FEDERAL AUTHORITIES, AND
POTENTIAL POLITICAL
PERSECUTION.
MANY ARE SAYING, I HAVE TALKED
TO A LOT OF FOLKS UP AND DOWN
THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM.
DOING THIS TO SUCH MAGNITUDE,
SUCH A SEARCH TO THIS EXTREME.
ANYTHING SHORT OF FINDING THE
NUCLEAR CODES AT MAR-A-LAGO IS
GOING TO HUGELY BACKFIRE ON THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
DONALD TRUMP, AS HE HAS SAID
AND MANY HAVE INDICATED HAS
REPLIED TO SOME DEGREE WITH THE
FEDERAL AUTHORITIES.
BUT, UNTIL WE FIND OUT MORE
ABOUT WHY THEY WENT TO THIS
EXTREME, PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BE
OUTRAGED.
I'M HEARING PEOPLE WHO ARE OVER
TRUMP AND MANY TO MOVE ON.
NOW THEY ARE GALVANIZED BEHIND
HIM AND SHOWING SUPPORT BECAUSE
THEY FEEL HE IS BEING SINGLED
OUT BY THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
>> SO, JOHN, TO ALICE'S POINT,
LEGALLY THAT IS NOT HOW IT
WORKS AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
YOU PRESENT AN AFFIDAVIT TO A
JUDGE.
YOU SAY HERE ARE THE SPECIFIC
RAISINS WHY WE THINK THERE IS
PROBABLE CAUSE THAT A FEDERAL
CRIME WAS COMMITTED.
YOU DO NOT RELEASE THAT.
THAT AFFIDAVIT IS UNDER SEAL.
IF UNTIL CHARGES ARE BROUGHT.
THAT IS HOW IT ALWAYS WORKS >>
THAT IS RIGHT, THAT IS WHY THE
IDEA THAT THIS WAS SOMEHOW DONE
IN SECRET DOES NOT LINE UP WITH
WHAT AN IMPARTIAL JUST INQUIRY
BY A JUSTICE WOULD ENTAIL.
THAT IS WHAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH.
I HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR
ALICE BUT I AM NOT BUYING THIS
IDEA THAT TRUMP PLAYING
SIMULTANEOUSLY VICTIM AND
AGGRESSOR CONSTANTLY.
BUT THIS IS SOMEHOW A
PERSECUTION.
THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
LET'S BE CLEAR, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, UNDER MERRICK
GARLAND HAS BEEN PROCEEDING IN
A WAY TO DE POLITICIZE ITS
WORK.
AND, WE WILL FIND OUT DETAILS,
IT IS APPRECIATE.
WE SHOULD ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT THIS.
>> APPOINTED BY TRUMP, BY THE
WAY.
>> IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT, JUST
A SHOULD BE NONPARTISAN.
THIS APPEARS TO BE A
NONPARTISAN PROCESS.
IT APPEARS TO BE RELATED TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT.
I DO NOT THINK FOR ONE SECOND
THAT TYPICALLY THE FBI WOULD
ASK FOR SEARCHING A FORMER
PRESIDENTS RESIDENCE IF IT WAS
SIMPLY UNDER THE CATEGORY OF A
MISDEMEANOR LET'S WAIT FOR ALL
OF THE FACTS THAT COME IN BUT
LET'S ENCOURAGE MY REPUBLICAN
FRIENDS TO THINK CONSISTENTLY
ABOUT THE RULE OF LAW.
SOMETHING THAT PARTY ALWAYS
HELD UP.
NOT TO RUSH THE PARTISAN
RAMPARTS AND COMPARING THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO A MARXIST
DICTATORSHIP, AS MARCO RUBIO
DID, RECENTLY.